after nine days of intense and emotional
chess action we are finally ready to
crown a king i am joined today by
augusta druggish the super bad
foundation president michael kodakowski
representing the granchester as well as
our victor maxim vashir lagrav michael
i'm going to give you the first words uh
thank you christian we just concluded
probably the most exciting start of the
season for the grand cheers tour with
three-way tie for first place uh with
the clear winner right now uh maximus
allegra from france
i would like
to congratulate our winner as well as
all uh
players who played here
an exciting
first leg of the grand chess tour i also
would like to thank our sponsors
superbad foundation one uh
united properties first bank and
many many fans who actually
uh
crowded
uh not only
uh whole
but also
uh where online and tens of thousands of
viewers today
look and watch this exciting round
exciting tie break
and i would like to pass the microphone
to the president of superbad foundation
augusta dragach
thank you
it's a great pleasure and a great honor
to have again gran chester and thank you
michael thank you all of you to have it
here for the third time in bucharest and
to see how many people so many kids they
are around this is the big
the the big pleasure of us to have as
many kids around the chest
so i'm thank you for the players and
especially for maxim and i'm happy to be
now uh the second time uh in the
position to offer you a prize i remember
last year on zagreb and i wish you to
happen on this situation as many times
so congratulations thank you to everyone
and please
thank you
so here is the prize it's yours
congratulations
maxime first of all uh i would like to
give you the word tell us about your
initial thoughts and feelings right now
after these incredible tie breaks
uh of course i feel very good uh but uh
i'm surprised i haven't
fainted or something it's been a very
long day
um
but yeah
[Music]
all in all uh
very good day for me like i won three
games so that's definitely uh
very positive uh i want the tournament
uh
you know after uh
helping me come back from uh you know
tough uh
few months where i was trying to qualify
for candidates and didn't manage so of
course it's a boost of confidence and uh
in general of course i would like to
thank uh
first of all the organizers for putting
up
a great a great event and absolutely
astounding event uh including the
opening ceremony at the parliament
and of course i would like to thank my
my family my friends everyone who's
cheered me up in the last
in the last few months and
helped me you know get
get back my energy
maxim you came into today's round with a
titanical task ahead of yourself you had
to beat alireza ferrugia one of the
hottest players on the circuit with the
black pieces how do you approach today's
game
i decided to play a very normal game
because i knew that user would not back
down from a fight
and actually tried very hard to win
as much as he could and
at some point it did backfire badly
you won that and then you had to wait
and see what wesley against aronian
happened and wesley won you were facing
wesley after that with the white pieces
almost in a must-win situation
how did you leave that moment in that
game
yeah that's right i was in a muslim
situation and i added not any
preparation because i was just trying to
recover from uh
from the exhausting game i played with
alireza so i just you know figured
things out at the board of course uh
opening didn't go well
uh and at some point um there were some
very scary moments but i did find some
some tricks uh this h3 move for instance
where quintex g3 doesn't work
and
yeah in the end i think it was a comedy
of blenders but with such a complicated
position and five seconds per move it
was bound to happen that was an
incredible display of intense chess
exactly what we like to see here at the
granchester maxim you have so many fans
around the world here in bucharest as
well what do you have to say to them
yeah just uh thank you it's you know
always
um
great to feel the support to feel uh you
know people waiting for you and
you know
like
again what
during the event i was approached and
stopped by by all the
the romanian chess fans i
i probably have received tons of message
by by now but i will check that later
ladies and gentlemen the 2022 superbad
chess classic winner maxim bashir
lagrave